Against the
backdrop of the Kremlin's
military struggles in Ukraine.
Unpleasant.
Vladimir Putin
says Russia will place
tactical nuclear weapons in Belarus.
Ukraine's northern neighbor
or risk border
as both Ukraine and non-NATO
ally, Poland.
It hasn't had a nuclear arsenal
since the end of the Cold War,
but that could change in
just a few months.
Here's how Putin defended
the move
in an interview with Russian media.
What you're seeing in this study,
the United States has done it
for decades.
They have placed
their tactical nuclear weapons
in their ally countries,
NATO countries,
in six countries, to be exact.
Germany, the Netherlands, Belgium,
Italy, Turkey and Greece.
And we had an agreement
with Lukashenko as allies do the same.
Then you've been monitoring
reaction there in Ukraine
What have you been seeing
Well, what we see is that
the Ukrainians
clearly feel
that the temperature is being raised
by President Putin's statement
regarding the deployment
of tactical nuclear weapons
sometime down the line in Belarus.
On the other hand,
they are not pressing the panic button.
We did see a statement
from Aleksey
Daniel of who's
a senior adviser to President
Vladimir Zelensky.
He said,
and I'm reading here
Putin's statement
about placing nuclear weapons in Belarus
a step towards internal destabilization
of the country.
Maximizes
the level of negative
perception and public rejection
of Russia.
And Putin in Belarus, Russian society.
The Kremlin,
he concluded, took Belarus
as a nuclear hostage.
I think if you read between the lines
here,
what do the Ukrainians are saying
that Lukashenko, whose hold on power
just a few years ago was looking
rather shaky
may be weakening his domestic position
by allowing Russia at some point
to deploy nuclear weapons in Belarus
and as.
As Matthew just mentioned,
the fact that this means
more Russian troops
in Belarus, a country
which did allow the Russians
to use their territory
to invade Ukraine just over a year ago.
All right.
And then, Ben, from the battlefront now.
What's the latest
particularly in the ongoing battle
for Bakhmut
Well, the situation there
continues to be precarious.
CNN was on the phone
with a senior official spokesman
for Ukrainian forces in eastern Ukraine.
He said that the Russians in the area
around Bakhmut
do not seem to be suffering
from a shortage
of artillery shells,
that the shelling of that city
continues to be intense.
He says that
there are around
4000 civilians incredibly
still inside what's left of that city.
Now, every day
we're seeing that the Russians
have advanced
in some areas,
the Ukrainians
claiming that they're pushing back
and others.
What's most important
is that
there is one
last road allowing for Ukrainian forces
to go in and out of the city
and to bring supplies and whatnot.
That road continues
to be quite dangerous.
And if if at some point
the Russians do manage to either
cut that road
or make it impassable because of fire,
that could spell
the end
of the Ukrainian military presence in
Barmore can.